a doctor  nice big house like this there is a ton  of cash we wait till they get back they  give us what we want  [Music]  me this  won't get you anywhere by prison maybe  don't do this  give me the combination which is no  they have to get into the hospital the  hospital is 30 miles away i seriously  doubt you could survive the journey  oh goodness you don't look at all well  please sit here  and wait for the ambulance to arrive  oh we really must fumigate this place  again soon  we're plagued by vermin every sort of  pest  we have to get out don't worry  everything will be fine i've told you a  thousand times shoes off  at the door she needs to be punished  she'll ruin everything very well  if that's what you want  tell me what's going on just a few  minutes more and then a lovely  long sleep  you